eunuch the spider
the master of whispers imp half man
there are faster ways to kill yourself
not for a coward
you are many things my friend but not a
coward
you never told me why you set me free
your brother asked me to
would have said no refuse the kingslayer
a dangerous proposition
not as dangerous as releasing me you
risked your life
your position everything why you you're
not family you owe me nothing
i didn't do it for you i did it for the
seven kingdoms
drunken dwarf will never be the savior
of the seven kingdoms
i don't believe in saviors i believe men
of talent have a part to play in the war
to come
going to have to find another soldier
done with westeros and westeros is done
with me
you have many admirable qualities
self-pity is not one of them
any fool with a bit of luck can find
himself born into power
but earning it for yourself that takes
work
not well suited for work i think you are
you have your father's instincts for
politics
and you have compassion compassion yes
i killed my lover with my bare hands
i shot my own father with a crossbow
i never said you were perfect what is it
you want
exactly peace
prosperity a land where the powerful do
not prey on the powers
where the castles are made of
gingerbread and the moats are filled
with blackberry wine
the powerful have always preyed on the
powerless that's how they became
powerful
in the first place perhaps perhaps we've
grown so
used to horror we assume there's no
other way
if you sat on the iron throne would you
spread misery throughout the land
i will never sit on the iron throne no
you won't
but you could help another climb those
steps and take that seat
the seven kingdoms need someone stronger
than tommen but gentler than stannis
a monarch who can intimidate the high
lords and inspire the people
a ruler loved by millions with a
powerful army and the right family name
good luck finding him
said anything about him
you have a choice my friend you can stay
here at illyrio's palace and drink
yourself to death
or you can ride with me to meereen meet
daenerys targaryen and decide if the
world is worth fighting for
can i drink myself to death on the road
to meereen
you